Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Wir müssen aber unserer Fußballkultur treu bleiben. Mit Fußballkultur treu bleiben meine ich eben, dass wir eben keine Halbzeitkonzerte machen, dass wir eben nicht irgendwelche großartigen Events um das Spiel machen. Ich glaube, Deutschland genauso wie England, da geht es wirklich um das Fußballspiel. Da geht es wirklich um diese 100 mal 60 Quadratmeter. Man möchte seinen Verein siegen sehen, man möchte den Rivalen bezwingen am langen Ende. Darum geht das.
Die Fußballkultur in Deutschland, wie soll sie aussehen? Wir hörten ein Zitat von Max Eberl, das er dem Kicker gegeben hat, vor zwei Jahren nun schon. Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen in diesem Tribünengespräch der besonderen Art. Warum, das erkläre ich gleich. Mein Name ist Max Sagobost, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und freue mich, dass ihr mal wieder mit dabei seid. Ja, warum ein Tribünengespräch der besonderen Art? Das hier ist das zweite Tribünengespräch, das wir vor Live-Publikum aufgezeichnet haben, das aber im Gegensatz zu der damaligen Folge, das war Tribünengespräch Nummer 11, zur Arbeit von Fußballkommentatoren und Moderatoren diesmal nicht als Tribünengespräch angelegt hat. Das heißt, das, was ihr jetzt dann im Folgenden hören könnt, ist die Aufzeichnung einer Diskussionsrunde, die ich am Rande des 11-Millimeter-Fußballfilmfestivals halten durfte und die eben erst mal auch das sein sollte. Eine Diskussionsrunde und kein klassisches Tribünengespräch. Dementsprechend widmen wir uns zwar einem Thema sehr eingehend, aber wir kommen zu keinem Ende. Das ist vielleicht aber bei diesem Thema auch gar nicht möglich. Worum es gleich gehen soll, sage ich euch. Aber vorher muss ich noch danken den Supportern Tom1211, Steve, Michi B., Daniel T und Michael BSC. Sie alle unterstützen den Rasenfunk finanziell und machen es damit möglich, dass wir euch auch solche Sendungen hier veröffentlichen können. Vielen herzlichen Dank dafür. Wer sich darüber informieren möchte, wie man uns unterstützen kann, findet ihr alle Infos dazu. Zusätzlich muss ich bei dieser Folge aber noch einer Reihe von weiteren Menschen danken, nicht nur Supporterinnen und Supporter. Ich danke zum einen ganz herzlich Jochen vom 11mm Fußballfilmfestival-Organisationsteam. Der hat die ganze Idee einer Podiumsdiskussion in Rollen gebracht und da auch viel eigene Zeit reingesteckt. Außerdem Jan, der uns ganz, ganz herausragend vor Ort bedient hat und dafür gesorgt hat, dass für alles gesorgt war, auch für die technische Möglichkeit, das hier aufzuzeichnen. Vielen herzlichen Dank an euch beide. Dann möchte ich ganz besonders nochmal Marvin und Katharina danken, dass sie sich darauf eingelassen haben, zu diesem Thema eine Diskussionsrunde beizuwohnen. Ihr werdet in gut anderthalb Stunden wissen, warum dieser Dank sehr, sehr gerechtfertigt ist. Und dann werdet ihr auch erfahren haben, warum es auf jeden Fall sich gehört, dass ich an der Stelle nochmal dem anwesenden Publikum danke, dass sich toll eingebracht hat, dass wie geplant die Perspektive nochmal erweitert hat und neue Denkimpulse und Denkanstöße gegeben hat zu diesem Thema. Worum soll es gehen? Fußballkultur 2.0. So ist der Titel dieses Tribünengesprächs. Das ist schon einigermaßen vage, so wie ja auch der Begriff der Fußballkultur ein Wager ist. Im Großen und Ganzen habe ich mir die Frage gestellt, ist die Fußballkultur, so wie wir sie propagieren, so wie sie in vielen Medien dargestellt wird, passt das noch in unsere Zeit oder gibt es nicht da einige Leerstellen, dunkle Flecken, die da nicht ganz mit abgebildet werden, vielleicht auch Entwicklungen, die aus der neueren Zeit kommen, seien sie digitaler Natur oder seien sie gesellschaftlicher Natur. Die Zeiten haben sich verändert, die dabei ein bisschen nicht mit gemeint werden, wenn wir über den Fußball sprechen, so wie wir ihn gerne hätten. Und so schwamm ich jetzt auch schon wieder diese Formulierung war, zeigt sich auch schon, es ist ein zu großes Thema, um das in einem Tribünengespräch zu besprechen. Und allein die Definition, die jeder einzelne und jeder einzelne von euch da draußen von Fußballkultur hat, wird schon mal wesentlich ausmachen, worüber man eigentlich redet. All das werdet ihr jetzt gleich in diesem Tribünengespräch hören. Wie gesagt, es ist in Live-Qualität, das heißt, das eine oder andere Mal ist es nicht perfekt ausgesteuert. Ich denke aber, es ist dennoch sehr gut hörbar und inhaltlich. Danke ich wirklich an der Stelle nochmal den beiden Gästen, die das sehr bereichert haben. Ich wünsche euch jetzt viel Spaß. Es geht direkt los mit der Podiumsdiskussion, die am 23. März beim 11-Millimeter-Fußballfilm-Festival in Berlin stattgefunden hat.
Ja, also ich bin Henry, ich bin auch bei Twitter unterwegs, ich bin derjenige, der den Jan Gobi vorhin angesprochen hat hier, wenn es um Thema Ostkurve und Hertha geht. Ich bin Herr Tanner. Eine Sache, das nur zur Erklärung, um den Jan vorhin einzuordnen. Nicht in der Ostkurve, nee. Ich will ja Fußball sehen und Hertha. Ihr seht doch, wie man das steht, ihr könnt ja nichts erkennen da drüben. Egal, darum geht's nicht. Es gibt ein Element beim Fußball, was natürlich wichtig ist zu erhalten. Preiswerte Plätze sorgen dafür, dass es zu erhalten bleibt und das ist das Thema, das normalen Chaos, das es im Fußballstadion gibt. Dass nämlich der Vater, der sonst immer ganz ordentlich ist, auf einmal richtig fluchen kann und schimpfen kann und den Schiri beschimpfen kann. Natürlich, sofern es sich im normalen Rahmen bewegt. Also nicht, wir reden hier nicht von irgendwelchen Unfleetigkeiten, aber einfach nur so, du dumme Sau und du hast doch keine Ahnung. Ja, das ist einfach ein Chaos, was ein Kind erleben kann, wie der gut situierte Vater auf einmal völlig aus sich herausgeht und seine gute Kinderstube völlig vergisst. Und das geht natürlich nur dann, wenn wir es uns leisten können, die Kinder weiterhin mit ins Stadion zu nehmen. Wenn natürlich ein Ticket in England einen absolut hohen Betrag kostet, wird es schon schwierig. In Berlin geht das alles noch, das ist wunderbar machbar, das ist bei Union genauso machbar wie bei Hertha, da kriegen wir es noch hin. Und ja, wir haben viel Platz bei uns im Olympiastadion, ja. Und wir nutzen den auch dementsprechend sehr kreativ und wir können auch Kinder wunderbar mit reinnehmen, das geht alles wunderbar. Deswegen nehmt eure Gören mit rein ins Stadion und lasst die richtig das Fußballerlebnis erleben und lasst die auch mal ruhig schimpfen. Und wenn die alten Säcke ringsrum stehen und schimpfen, dann ist das für die Kinder. Dann ziehen sie zwar den Kopf ein und gucken auf die Eltern und fragen, opa, ja, das machen wir zu Hause aber nicht. Ja, dann ist das eben so, ist nämlich Fußball. Und Fußball ist eben auch immer ein bisschen chaotisch.
Ich hab mir ja gewünscht, diese Diskussion über Fußballkultur zusammen mit Max. Wir haben das entwickelt und was ich jetzt wieder feststelle, wir reden wieder quasi fast ausschließlich über das Stadion-Erlebnis. Wir, die wir hier dieses Fußball-Film-Festival organisieren, das ist ein kleiner Verein, Brot und Spiele e.V., da sind Leute drin, die Fußball und Kultur, Fußball und Bildung fördern wollen. Und wir machen uns natürlich Gedanken darüber, wie kriegen wir eine andere Zielgruppe dazu, uns zu unterstützen, bei uns mitzumachen, eigene Ideen zu entwickeln und woanders hinzugehen. Genauso mit dem Festival. Wenn ich mich jetzt hier umgucke, was wir in diesem Podcast dann wahrscheinlich nicht hinkriegen, aber es ist wieder überwiegend, es sind Männer meiner Generation, mit ein paar Frauen dazwischen und ein paar Leute, die doch viele Leute, die jünger sind. Aber diese, über die wir jetzt hier reden, über die reden wir wieder. Also außer Marvin, der sich ja irgendwie selber älter macht, als er ist. Und deswegen meine Frage geht in die Richtung, wie können wir ein Kulturangebot außerhalb der Stadien? Gibt es da etwas, was man mit Fußball verbindet? Wir haben Ausstellungen, wir haben Lesungen, wir haben diese Diskussion und wir zeigen ganz viele Filme. Das ist Kino, da ist schwierig mit Stehplatz. Da sitzen die meisten. Das würde mich total interessieren, ob ihr dazu eine Meinung habt, was wir mehr machen können, inwieweit ihr uns unterstützen könnt, inwieweit ihr dazukommen wollt.
Ja, oder ja anders gefragt. Marvin, wo sind denn die großen Fußball-YouTuber? Zu fast jedem Bereich gibt es große YouTuber, große Influencer im Fußballbereich. Manu Thiele würde mir als einer einfallen, dann gibt es ein paar Medien, die versuchen, sich als Influencer zu positionieren. Aber wo bleiben die denn?
In Deutschland lassen sie noch auf sich warten. Ich glaube, wenn man nach England schaut, dann gibt es da eine Art von YouTubern, Club-YouTuber, sei es jetzt Arsenal, z.B. The Anfield Rap, bei Liverpool, die eine ganz andere Art zwischen Fan und Journalist auf ihren Verein blicken. Aber zu der Frage, wie man junge Leute außerhalb des Stadions begeistert, also ich glaube, so leid es mir um die Kultur geht, es wird halt irgendwo über Entertainment laufen. Und dann ist es halt tatsächlich für junge Fans eher die Netflix-Doku über Juventus Turin als aktuell die Lesung über ein sehr, sehr gutes Fußballbuch über Fußballtaktik von Tobi Escher. Tobi Escher erreicht die dann bei Rocket Beans TV. Also deswegen, ich fürchte, dass es da halt über Entertainment geht und wie weit dann Dokumentationen über Manchester City wie All or Nothing, wo ich sagen muss, dass die US-Varianten irgendwie im Football doch irgendwie mir da mehr gegeben haben, weil ich es authentischer fand als bei Manchester City. Aber das ist ja die Art, wie junge Fans auch Fußball konsumieren. Und es ist ja kein, es kommt ja nicht von ungefähr, dass auch bei den Freekickers halt die Fußballstars ein- und ausgehen, weil nämlich auch die Ausrüster sagen, naja, du gehst da jetzt hin, drehst mit denen eine Stunde, dann entsteht dabei ein YouTube-Clip und das ist irgendwie, das ist für uns relevanter, als irgendwie beim Intersport eine Autogrammstunde zu geben. Also da haben halt sich die Zeiten halt deutlich verändert.
Ja, Glück auf, ich bin der Jan. Ich bin halt zehn Minuten vom Duisburg Stadion aufgewachsen, aber mit Schalke sozialisiert worden, so vom Freundeskreis her. Und was ich festgestellt habe, ist einfach, dass ganz viel so in meiner Generation um Aufmerksamkeitsspannen geht. Von mir aus eine Stunde Anreise zum Stadion, dann vor Ort Abreise, eventuell, wenn man noch im Pkw unterwegs ist, noch mal länger, weil öffentliche Verkehrsmittel nicht funktionieren. Und das ist einfach für viele Leute in meiner Generation zu viel Zeit. So, da haben die keine Lust drauf. Die machen dann lieber zur Halbzeit die Sky-Konferenz an, gucken das, gucken danach noch vielleicht eine halbe Folge bei Netflix von der Doku und machen dann abends wieder irgendwas anderes. Und die Anzahl der Leute, die wirklich losgehen und sagen, okay, ich nehme jetzt eine Auswärtsfahrt mit, die kann ich bei mir, an der Schule konnte ich die an einer Hand abzählen. So, und das ist halt, glaube ich, noch mal was ganz anderes, weil auch der ganze Medienkonsum gänzlich anders geworden ist, als der vielleicht noch vor 20 oder 30 Jahren war, wo es vollkommen normal war, dass man wirklich sich auch hingesetzt hat und einen Artikel mal gelesen hat. Heutzutage ein Elf-Freunde-Artikel für viele Leute, die blättern da einmal drüber, lesen die Bildunterschriften und das war's. Danach ist halt die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne im Kopf vorbei. Nee, gut, das war's eigentlich schon.
Also ganz wichtig, immer so ans Kinn halten, hab ich mal gelernt. Den Mikrofon kann man vielleicht, naja bei euch nicht. Ja, nee, ich will auf deine Frage antworten. Also ich habe vor drei, vier Jahren angefangen, irgendwann so in die Podcast-Szenerin zu gucken. Ein bisschen drauf gekommen bin ich, weil die, Stephanie von Texifa gehen, weil die den State of the Union jeden Tag veröffentlicht haben und da haben sie dann auch immer veröffentlicht, dass sie mal wieder aufnehmen und irgendwann habe ich mir das angehört und habe gedacht, wow, das ist ja geil, da sprechen Leute über Fußball. Dann haben sie gesagt, nee, dann hat da irgendwann mal den Max vom Rasenfunk da gehabt, der Sebastian. Und ich habe gesagt, ach, kuck mal, Rasenfunk gibt es auch. So, dann hat er die Leute von Damenwahl gegrüßt, ach, kuck mal, gibt es ja noch mehr. Und dann kam es wirklich so, dass ich ganz, ganz viele Podcasts konsumiere und über ganz, ganz viele Vereine teilweise besser Bescheid weiß als die eigenen Fans da. Also, ich kann ihnen da manchmal was erzählen, und bei mir auf Arbeit, wenn ich sage, ey, bei Hertha, hier, was ist denn da? Hab ich dir nicht von gehört. Nein, die wissen auch Bescheid. Aber wie gesagt, es ist total interessant und deswegen bin ich auch Rasenfunk-Supporter geworden.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Und ich sag mal, das ist eine Sache, die kannst du hören, wann du willst. Da kannst du nach Hause kommen und erst mal noch deinen Fußball 2000 YouTube-Kanal konsumieren und danach den Podcast hören. Ich finde auch, das habe ich als erstes gesagt, bevor ich da gesessen habe, lebendige Zeugen sitzen da. Max redet heute zu langsam, weil ich 1,2 höre. Das ist ganz merkwürdig, du kannst es auch schneller hören. Dann dauert es nur 4 Stunden. Genau. Und ich sage mal, darüber kriegst du unheimlich viel Community und der Hass auf andere Vereine lässt richtig nach. Ich fieber teilweise mit Hertha mit.
Ganz kurz bloß, ich frag wirklich noch mal, bei was wir uns gerade unterhalten, weil es sind doppelt so viele Zuschauer in den Stadien als zu der Zeit, als ich das erste Mal nach Berlin gekommen bin, sind es zwar bundesweit, wenn ich es richtig erinnere, in der Bundesliga einen Zuschauerschnitt von unter 20.000 pro Spiel, inzwischen haben wir einen Zuschauerschnitt von 35.000 oder 40.000. Ich behaupte jetzt mal, dass nicht die Alten zusätzlich in Stadien gekommen sind, sondern die, die damals vielleicht so die Jungen waren, sind trotzdem mit in die Stadien gegangen. Und jeder von uns damals Mittelalten, jetzt Altensecken hat gesagt, die sind aber komisch, aber es wächst ja pausenlos nach. Also ich verstehe wirklich nicht, warum wir uns gerade darüber unterhalten, dass keine Jungen da sind. Es sind genug Jungen im Stadion, wir sehen sie vielleicht nicht oder wir beobachten sie vielleicht nicht. Und auf die Frage, wie kriege ich die Kultur hin, indem ich, das ist jetzt ganz banal und ganz böse, indem ich für Kultur sorge und tolle Fotografien, tolle Clips, tolle irgendwas mache, was auch passt, dass ich eben auch mit wirklichen Kori-Fan versuche, das Fußballerlebnis einzufangen. Und das haben wir ja auch vielmehr. Es gab früher keine Fußballfilme. Es gab Helmut Zorke, der ein Buch geschrieben hat oder sonst irgendwas. Diese ganze Kultur gab es doch überhaupt nicht. Sanderländel, I die. Früher habe ich dich getötet für so ein Doku. Sonst gab es doch alles nicht. Wenn waren es marodierende Horten, und die gab es übrigens wirklich. 89, Rotterdam. Eine der größten Straßenschlachten rund um das Länderspiel, das es je gab. Jetzt haben wir wieder ein Spiel gegen Holland. Ich bin momentan außerhalb des Themenkreises, über den ihr euch gerade unterhaltet, weil ich irgendwie eine andere Erinnerung, eine andere Vergangenheit und andere Fakten im Kopf habe.
Guten Tag, ich will eigentlich eher noch was Positives sagen. Ich habe die These, dass das, was sich im Fußball verändert hat, du hast am Anfang irgendwie von dem Bezug auf die 80er und 90er gesprochen, im Vergleich zu heute, dass das Teil einer gesamtgesellschaftlichen Veränderung ist. Ich nenne es mal die totale Durchdringung sämtlicher gesellschaftlicher Ebenen durch den Verwertungsgedanken. So das Kommerzialisierung könnte man es auch nennen oder der moderne Fußball. Und ich erlebe im Fußball, dass es da Widerstand gibt. Also ich bin kein Freund dieses totalen Durchdringung. Und im Fußball gibt es Widerstand dagegen. Also im Stadion oder in Diskussionen wie hier oder in Magazinen mit Freunden oder was weiß ich. In anderen gesellschaftlichen Bereichen gibt es den überhaupt nicht. Obwohl die die kommerzielle Durchdringung genauso stark dort stattfindet. Wohnungsbereich oder was weiß ich, Gesundheitsbereich etc. Sämtliche andere kulturelle Bereiche. Überall passiert genau das gleiche. Aber es gibt keinen großen Widerstand. Hier beim Fußball gibt es ihn. Und das finde ich ist ein positiver Gedanke. Oder ist meine Grundthese falsch, das kann man natürlich sagen.
Ich hab da nichts zu ergänzen, außer dass ich genau deswegen die Diskussion aufmachen wollte, weil ich wusste, dass ihr noch schlauere Sachen sagt als wir. Das öffnet die Perspektive.
Ja, hallo, ich bin der Kai, ich bin Fan vom ersten FSV um 1.05. Das war jetzt nicht so entertaining das letzte Wochenende, aber es war auch okay. Zwei geteilte Sachen und zwar, das hat Herr Streich auch schon mal angesprochen, wer hat denn diese Welt gemacht, in der wir jetzt leben? Das waren nicht junge Leute und ich weiß nicht, ich finde es ehrlich gesagt immer ein bisschen arrogant, darauf zu runterzuschauen. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht mehr derjenige, der jetzt wahrscheinlich hier unter Jugend zählt. Immer noch? Also ich bin 27, ich weiß jetzt nicht, mit 15-Jährigen, das ist schon nochmal ein anderer, also wie man dort Fußball konsumiert, ist natürlich auch eine andere Art. Aber die Kommunzialisierung, wer hat diese Kommunzialisierung eingeleitet? Das waren nicht junge Leute, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass das Opfer davon sind, weil ich konsumiere Fußball auch noch anders. Und dann muss man sich ja schon mal überlegen, wenn wir ehrlich sind, wollen wir im Stadion ja schon Entertainment haben. Die Frage ist nur, welches Level sollte dieses Entertainment erreichen? Und ich finde es auch eigentlich gar nicht schlimm, solange man das mit anderen Elementen quasi vereinbart. Wenn man sich engagiert, wenn man sogar noch politische Aussagen machen kann, in Form von Transparenten, an einem ziemlich hohen Publikum, also was sich an ein recht hohes und viel Publikum quasi wendet. Und wenn man dann auch noch mal gepflegt die Sau rauslassen kann, dann finde ich, ist es auch immer noch für junge Leute attraktiv. Wenn man mehrere Sachen vereint, es muss ja nicht immer eins zum Extrem sein, aber wenn man diese Sachen immer noch vereinen kann im Fußballstadion, und das kann man auch in der Bundesliga, in der Premier League sieht das anders aus, das ist richtig. Aber ich finde, so lange gehen wir in der Bundesliga auch noch einen richtigen Weg. Und das jetzt auch noch mal als Positiv.
Also ich hätte vielleicht doch Widerspruch zu dem Beitrag davor, weil ich teile sozusagen die Einschätzung, die du gemacht hast, aber ich sehe nicht den großen Widerstand. Also das ist ja das, was ich vorhin schon mal meinte. Ich habe so das Gefühl, mit zunehmenden Generationen, es gibt so dieses Gemurre, ist ja voll blöd, dass alles so durchkommerzialisiert ist, aber wo gibt es denn wirklich einen Widerstand? Und ich habe so oft in den letzten Jahren gedacht, es gab ja immer auch mal erfolgreiche Protestaktionen, dass eigentlich die Fußballfans eine echte politische Macht sein könnten, wenn sie daraus, also ich sage immer jetzt nur, statt irgendwie 12 Minuten Protest am Anfang eines Spiels, könntest du ja wirklich mal gemeinsam eine riesengroße Demonstration auf die Beine stellen, weil es einfach wahnsinnig viele Fußballfans gibt und wenn die zusammen auf die Straße gehen würden, wenn die einen Protest auf eine andere Art und Weise machen würden, als nur so ein bisschen symbolisch ein Protest, wäre da ja mehr möglich. Also vielleicht, sag noch mal ein Beispiel, wo du siehst, dass es einen erfolgreichen Widerstand oder ernsthaften Widerstand dagegen gibt. Ich meine, selbst die Montagsspiele werden ja nicht gestrichen, weil die Leute die Schnauze voll hatten und es geärgert hat, sondern weil sie nicht lukrativ sind. Also nachher auch eher aus genau diesen Verwertungsinteressen heraus, sich nicht als erfolgreich erwiesen haben, werden die wieder gestrichen und nicht, weil sich irgendwie Fenster gegengewehrt hätten.
Ja, du hast wahrscheinlich recht. Ich sollte wahrscheinlich das Wort Widerstand irgendwie abschwächen. Wir sind hier zum Beispiel in einem kleinen Kino, von dem es früher überall welche gab, wie dieses Kino. Heutzutage gibt es halt ein paar große, riesige Multiplexe und kleine Kinos wie diese gibt es in einer Großstadt wie Berlin, gibt es noch ein paar, aber auch viel, viel, viel weniger als früher und in kleinen Städten gar nicht mehr. Da gibt es keinerlei, noch nicht mal Morden. Wenn ich jetzt in meiner Twitter-Timeline gucke, dann sehe ich Leute, die politisch anders positioniert sind als ich, die sich aber gegen diesen modernen Fußball und gegen diese Kommerzialisierung trotzdem wehren. Das ist das, was ich mit Widerstand meinte. Es gibt ein Bewusstsein darüber, dass da irgendwie was vielleicht falsch läuft. Und auch eine Bereitschaft, sich dagegen zu äußern. Widerstand nehme ich zurück. War Quatsch.
So, eine Wortmeldung noch, dann müssen wir, glaube ich.
Also vielleicht auch nochmal Andreas und dir was, also das ist ja wirklich so, wir haben heute ja auch Möglichkeiten, tatsächlich kulturell tätig zu werden und gehört zu werden, ohne dass du groß was brauchst. Also ein Wordpress-Blog, der geht ziemlich schnell, sogar Podcasts kann man irgendwie relativ schnell aufnehmen. Also vielleicht auch mal die positive Sache ist, es gibt eine Art und Weise von Kultur, die sich entwickelt hat, die eben nur digital geht. Das war früher anders, wenn du früher irgendwie ein Fan-Sein machen musstest, brauchtest du auf alle Fälle eine Schreibmaschine, du brauchst jemanden, der ein bisschen was verstand und du musst es kopieren und dann muss es es noch irgendwo loskriegen. Also ich erinnere mich noch an Leute, die durch Kneipen gezogen sind und Fan-Seins verkauft haben. Das ist heute einfacher geworden. Also es ist eigentlich tatsächlich mit der Digitalisierung einfacher geworden und da gebe ich Andreas z.B. total Recht, wenn er sagt, wir sind ja eigentlich auf einem guten Weg. Also auch wenn du sagst Widerstand, naja vielleicht klar, es ist keine große Demo da, aber man kann sich auf alle Fälle organisieren und man kann Leute finden, die mit einem einer Meinung sind. Also ich kenne einige Leute nur von Twitter, mit denen ich jetzt irgendwie, hallo. Und das ist vielleicht auch die Sache mit der Kultur. Also vielleicht findet Fußballkultur heute auch ein Nischen statt, die früher gar nicht bedient werden konnten. Das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Also das ist vielleicht eben auch so eine Sache. Man muss die Nischen suchen und das ist manchmal schwierig, das gebe ich auch zu. Also es gibt manchmal, wenn man wirklich zum Beispiel einen Fußball-Blog sucht, findet man auch irgendwelche Leichen von 2012. Immer noch, manchmal ja. Ist aber auch ganz spannend dann zu weilen, zu sehen, was damals geschrieben wurde. Also ich möchte ein relativ positives Fazit eigentlich ziehen. Es gibt eine Fußballkultur, die sich entwickelt und die auch was damit zu tun hat, dass sich die Gesellschaft verändert hat. Und ich denke, die Sichtbarkeit, dafür müssen wir halt alle sorgen. Das ist dann wieder das andere Ding.
Ja, ich bin enttäuscht. Ich dachte natürlich, dass wir jetzt den Wikipedia-Artikel Fußballkultur komplett neu schreiben können und da noch drei Sätze drin stehen und dann haben wir es fertig erklärt. Nein, es ist so ähnlich gelaufen, wie man es erwarten konnte. Es ist ein riesiges Thema und jeder hat vor allem seinen persönlichen Standpunkt. Ich möchte euch ganz herzlich dafür danken, dass ihr nochmal unsere Standpunkte erweitert habt. Das war Sinn und Zweck des Ganzen. Wir waren ja eher so quasi die Anstoßgeber und das alles hätte aber nicht so gut ins Rollen kommen können, ohne meine beiden Gäste, bei denen ich mich nochmal ganz herzlich bedanken möchte und euch dazu herauffordere, dass ihr so laut applaudiert wie noch nie in eurem Leben. Ich danke sehr herzlich Katharina Dahme und Marvin Ronsdorf.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück um die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.